okay tier list every single manga anime
I've ever reviewed let's go GT D tier
it's all right but compared to the rest
kinda mid Dragon Ball super better than
GT still mid C tier classic Dragon Ball
series incredible series but the demon
king piccoloark is plagued with contrive
and so a tier one piece fantastic work
of fiction with better writing and World
building than practically anything I've
seen a tier Hunter absolutely brilliant
as well as depressing eightier JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure love the manga not a
big fan of the anime solid beat here for
me Naruto do I even need to explain a
tier bleach from what I've seen so far
it's gotta be a solid beat here at least
Full Metal Alchemist fully deserving of
s tier don't at me mob psycho 100 near
perfect s tier chainsaw man great manga
pretty good anime a tier Attack on Titan
probably the most hooked I've ever been
on a work of fiction s tier Death Note
first half great second half all right a
tier I guess berserk literally changed
my life the most s of all the s tiers